yeah man I'm left without Ruben buying
Christmas sweaters did you get one but
David's Allen yeah they were like home
hell yeah Christmas Christmas see gift
yeah man compiled a man is conscious you
know what I want to see though what
shall we eat and Elsie Pancho baking
Christmas cookies together whatever they
want to wear you know but just them
together bro leg was like no we had mrs.
field was I know because of the red with
a red logo another one they went through
one time but them over here Leslie how
those soft - no song the first time I
had a month
I don't know that no the thing you know
we never had you can put a piece of
bread inside the bag absorb the moisture
oh shut up you said anything on
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was insane
into a guru house because I heard it
anyways bad so we get there and then it
doesn't white dude who blue house right
we pulled in the parking lot and we
heard this woman screaming yeah and
she's running after him with this other
woman and this guy runs into noodle
world with the little puppy right you
can't even see it it's so small so
teacups
yeah and it's a Mountie some baby
Morty's yeah trying to beat him up to
get the dog that she like Greg the
hammer Valentine
so what happened what happened was this
man now that woman the one that look
like Greg the hammer Valentine you know
there was our daughter right and I'm
sure like damn yeah that was someone who
lives in who lives so like somewhere
abroad like near Ohio or Illinois that
little area bro Wichita Kansas yeah man
like her lays never seen the Sun just
tasty dog food my boy you know April 8th
grade over here bro is mom you know she
really likes you the white woman up on
the horse County with a little bit of
cash you don't get out man good some of
her heels there were no white road I
should be walking us there
you know yourself so what happened was
great have a bad time woman who and her
daughter
they sell Maltese on Craigslist they
sold their my Maltese for nine hundred
dollars a week before and they died died
so they wanted their money back money
back this would happen bro California
white guy man if he he watch too much TV
first of all these steps meet us at the
noodle noodle world they pretend to buy
a new dog dog then we get there
snatch it up ahead of crime so when I
get there broke that their dual fence
they change their dues with Thai noodle
world you wanna take the dog so she's
being a he'd been attacked by a great
the hammer and then the one bring the
dog and put her chest
[Music]
so then the police come July they
driving by I go Carlo and I push my
video up on Instagram store immediately
I wrote white people be like and you
know that hashtag white people Saturday
so I put that up there right so the
police is asking everybody what's going
down or asking that woman what happened
whatever right they don't they give that
woman a ticket for beating up bring the
hammer
oh good job we gonna shuck the corn yeah
so they're asking me if I could see that
video then I told a cop listen man
before I show it to you I already
because you're people you saw that [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you had a heart attack
mister save me that [ __ ] oh my Stemmons
police officer and then they all share
it in it oh can I buy you a showgirl
sold out like it was it could escalate
it and the police officers say that
straight out that they're lucky they
didn't get worse like beating about
words or bringing out a gun oh yeah man
I guess it wasn't that ghetto there know
if you're listening man that's not the
way you do things so I don't know what
time will you do my bicycle try to be a
little bored and I said you know they
took it from the courts do you want a
Porsche then it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] LS it a
my hope you get a good money for that
myth that was shot at me mm-hmm so some
dude told me what we should do dawg put
up put up a reward for lost buying for
your bike five hundred dollars and when
your bike shows up bro just take your
bike back come on man ain't somebody
gonna be pissed cause into the prize
yeah man magic no but they stay there
because only the Steve is gonna show
with a bike the same fool to have it
done idiot oh yeah that's why those
people did that [ __ ] to that lady those
900 bucks thought I harmed your
daughter's in cash
that's what would've died probably like
a month after maybe not but still not
sure that's a chance you take first of
all man you do not make dog deals on
Craigslist you make
yogoro speakers washing my corn de
boville with a banger Devon and down
that's your first of all yeah man and it
so do shows Dokdo from hazard thing and
then they say hey homie yo buy some
speakers so it's alkane I'll buy some
speakers that's gonna be good yeah they
sound good and then I took a whole
brother ain't working oh so what the
[ __ ] was he using for the single know
where they work where they work that
well but the price heard about any
little story about like you know getting
Robbie my dad who so sure that that too
bro
so know this guy named different story
but it's a guy named Eli right and he
let the garage to fix everybody's car
right shut up - wrong you know I'm
talking about color like channels bro no
because the first time they got showed
up you were worried are all whites too
much huh so you know military channels
so all these fools in the fabric over
like 15 deep bro they were all athletic
bro and the older brother he to take
those little ones and make a teacher how
to do gymnastics bro and they're like
hey want to the four parts of enough a
stock ready for the liberal rushes so
Manuel wraps around the project so just
like yeah yeah
so bad no somebody stole a truck I see
us grow our pickle truck bro our pickup
truck at Sears they stole the whole car
it was gone up my phone that's just a
word like in the West I have rolling
over there was a shot white men can't
Joseph right yeah without the camper so
we found a trail all messed up
then at Kmart broke out of a toilet over
at Kmart that's the story we're a
keyboard and write that recognizes camp
yeah and K boy
and then my that's it like oh look
around Oh like the cry I don't know what
you say the crime
so they check the truck originally at
Sears and you found the cameras came on
Kmart broke
damn dude so they stole a car man and a
super a market for Less my brother angel
the one who love mi a you know you can't
come over here because I Paul has two
and a half strikes one more he's done so
we have to like come back
illegally bring a fax of they wanna buy
the bridge we made that to the camper
the camper yeah the camper so my angel
told me that my dad was in Mexico he
said let's do it again
do they [ __ ] it they stole the truck and
my dad said no Mike my brother said that
my dad is friend were partying I get
loose button ID and they saw that fool
from Kmart driving my dad's truck with
the camper and get them yeah so I don't
know man so my pocket my dad a friend
started chasing a fool for Mexico to
kill you man
why this get so personal by truck I'm
thinking about that little fuzzy why our
sorry do campers popular back mate
oh yeah but
oh boy icon sharply flu was be it was
like that was brown at first yeah you
have my own neighborhood
in the other neighborhood over there
old school everywhere bro which one
forgive the headhunters that's an
old-school neighborhood man we talked
about in a podcast the headhunters so
they started around with nineteen
eighty-something
there were they actually to be a
football team and they still wear a Lana
Hawks your Z's bro their jerseys were a
lot of popular teen or black and red
yeah turn it off like a football team
but didn't even give a gang we're now
you know crack started coming around bro
you don't want to get paid and stay
without ms-13 because they to be called
Marisa to just owners
team back in the day yes don't know baby
yeah you got you gotta you gotta pay
extra $10 to know that two weeks ago so
used to read without glasses December 14
through 17
Addison in private Addison Texas you
were listening to this day on a Friday
night all right
in January
it's gonna be happening that's happening
at the Ice House in Pasadena
[Laughter]
that's the homie he's the one that did
the stand-up comedy in the first
anniversary live podcast yeah he has
opened up for every always talked about
it but yeah man you know be there as
well October December 28 27
yes territory service at the Ice House
of Pasadena there's gonna be two shows
just one show for Flaco man
to get a more beers little drinks always
straws in it yeah so he'll be there man
also mention here shut up bro come on
bro to all the items iTunes reviewers
are Scott from Turlock California
Turlock Matt from Minnesota
German boat owners in Dallas see you in
Addison this week deep though the fool
mugs three one oh thanks for coming out
this past week patty Carlson supervisor
it was intense
yeah man you know whose waiver I'm at
280 right now you been doing any bad boy
he made policy with PI about 280 I wanna
be like this guy hey watch out I don't
know the window take you go yeah big bro
you push it every day let go I'm like a
prison body bro
I think when they tell you all yeah the
home is eating healthy is very full Man
Man Man what at night Oh see some tea
mom para jiggidy p.m. hey yeah don't you
get it the only games but who picks up
its bones who texted me let me go to it
either when I check my email Lisa finds
out so there's the e fund me for a
documentary you know kids
yeah right right you know it's crossing
and then about two hundred thousand of
them don't make it so they go missing
whether they're being sold whether
they're died they've been killed
well gentlemen I'm proud to say that I
am the last slice well back there man
but the people they're not coming from
Mexico or what I think why now go out
the first that was the first the first
wave of our immigrants are coming out
here cuz I know that most of the
Colombian I would come they were flying
out here really I cash to come over here
no no no Colombia's coming here
illegally but our Mexican will coming in
from that vehicle from Juarez Sinaloa
another
every word what the mother leaves even
though there's a lot of fools coming
through there even stuff connects it but
anyways so the documentary is about the
moms who are looking for the kids did he
get sent by themselves yeah but they
weren't always kids it might have been
they're spending some you're made it
back to them like a thank you send out
your kids but did you ever know that
they have penalties over breastfeed but
these moms they do a pilgrimage every
year a bus has to go look for them or to
honor or death or how many are they
found the documentary is about the women
nobody knows like a whole so when I saw
it I was like well man if you're like a
vice documentary you know or it could be
like oh it's gonna be a movie of course
a documentary so I say you know I'm like
man money so I do it I don't any money
bro I became one of the coal producers
so I'm co-producing this movie
where's parle-g is there someone else I
guess what's a leave of absence so so
it'll be a movie coming out and I'm
proud happy that I'm part of it are they
still working on it
the people who know I think they're
trying to raise $30,000 or to complete
their travels because they're doing two
more trips yeah
oh there are 28,000 just a couple
thousand ago but it's flexible they get
the funding whether or not they need
that goal so yeah together a trailer and
yes apologia with the one hour talking
let me tell you
so you're bad and also I'm doing a movie
I'm shooting our independent movie
called
Ricardo oh yeah I don't know with a mic
finally for the information the four one
one that knowledge is power centers
[Laughter]
shout out to multi marine or whoever and
on Jorge Perez I think Eddie Jean Riley
oh my god G Riley and beanie Lisa we're
at the yo yo yo party extravaganza
podcast which was insane insane the hell
are we like to watch it on Martin's
Facebook live I don't know how long's
gonna be there but it will there there a
porn star there bro that up the dating
game matter that dating game was so
dirty broke I know I [ __ ] cold sore
in the back to arena sure to Ranger
Gonzalez Vasquez
I am so hooked on your podcast thank you
very much
right now please tell all your friends
man we need more women to get into
podcasts yeah yeah it was crazy for
everyone showed up bro I will let the
who's who I was looking around to see
what I could eat they apart Dulce broke
my elbow they had that ruler donut new
tire Melissa fell asleep and I got doing
some almonds and I ate half of the
elements for they get up to 11
well get up at 8:00 but I'm gonna eat
but I felt like a held up like I felt
like I was carrying a person on my
shoulders I thought I don't carry that
got a little person I don't care if
right now it goes carabineer or my lap
okay Rizal bro and I just like address
of scope present water wear to bed roll
good out and they will snap for another
three hours
I don't know the man with a girl was but
yes I don't do them yeah it was good
anyways bro I'm gonna guess here bro
punch alright
yeah we searching here man and I say you
know I have a podcast
well this food I found like eight months
ago right here is the best thing there
all right well then I say this cholo bro
material bro you don't public cheering
at their poker chip yeah so I saw him
there bro like something like blood
whatever
Bob Baker marionette in the little part
is right there work it's like in the
middle man between that way too if that
we Street another place bro it's like
neutral now tell ya brother well the
only play well why people go in a
neighborhood female
and now he's a to my pocket colonia yeah
30 bro if you don't know that's where
the neighborhood they will take whatever
we're burning your trash is like
everybody to pull a bunch of borrows in
an empty lot to break up you can chose
Bali bro submit
yeah yeah so yeah they will let me
Harley let me go outside
well my cousin playing soccer
he doesn't always leave em like where I
will still go aside I mean
we get ourselves a migraine so he would
think of like um like fire was like you
know like their age so they let us go
for free and so it was good like war
over here for permanent moving to from a
money they will let us o my brothers to
be here for like chemical war like in a
house on right enzyme go for like and
it's like five months no cuz I was just
trying to press a house oh that's those
useful deeper like yeah we're there for
like five months and then we just say
lettuce all right you know the kids let
it go for like my hands that used to be
here my dad you know but of course stuff
like that and at the end what if I know
probably is like you know like almost a
year and then at the time they would ask
in my definite you know try thousand
dollars to stay here so my that was it
right you know now and there was his
name
they feel like you're not trying to go
back it would be a lot more money to you
part of the what the DREAM Act rope
relator was Lincoln there's crazy right
along with those it wasn't my seat I you
know I didn't keep you know my maths and
yeah you know you know like I was
English because I mean I grew up in
every around were like it was just you
know kids you know grow here and there
and like three buildings around and
crazy right and brother Daniel 42 Hades
would also they time jerseys - yeah just
like right there you see them also on
Glendale Avenue - you see their people
each live there that's crazy
[Laughter]
you know you know just being like home
and stuff like that goes I mean I kind
of practically know where everything's
at in I know where I could walk through
it you know where I'm not to work if you
are Lucilla discrimination against you
because you're a fighter for no Mexicans
over here like okay bye sir
I was coming like since they knew that I
can I would like you know Saahil I was
in my car departs from her like hey
where it kind of like knows me you know
like I'm a medic medic in a bad way
because even though I used to you know
be like not texting people where I will
go with these like a bunch of people
using our Salafi people left and right a
removal notice people you know something
that will hide from me put on I'll never
joined the hood cuz I'm not coming to
join like a gang or something that will
come in right and then we'll send me
back your window I am I going down
Farber like I gotta you know trying to
sing back or 19,000 only reason that I
kind of feeling like kind of stomach to
like I mean I was just a crazy
you see like find anything I'll just
give it like a little sample like
everyday magnet is not anymore but like
I'm trying to stay back into the show
can we do like I show the theater like a
pain in the morning and then I will
leave the theater like at all dude I
will going to MacArthur Park right in
the Metro like obviously be like you
know posting we share in just be like
you know find the other homies right
there and just start smoking go a street
and I mean this fool just you know
depending on how people were like we'll
go to the inside of the streets because
everybody would be awesome there in you
I mean this was no I mean I know we're
like mostly Mackerras you know parada
I'm not like right there we they put me
killing me Caro McKellen I gathered
simple like you know think oh they'll be
good on Vaqueros funny man oh well geo
said that when you when you go by though
the fake green card you gotta put your
hand out like this crazy girl giggle at
this that's been going for a green card
right there MacArthur Park a street all
the way too far to Beverly that's been
going off for years huh
you can't stop it huh yeah tell me how
how technical people get in making these
green cards like I know something that
I've been into a place where I go and
throw a band and I get down on my knees
like a parade and they take a photo for
me think I charge me $10 and those
photos live it or not they're good
enough to get a basically a passport
yeah yeah like a regular IDs around
there so you could just take a picture
and inspiring just grab the information
like you know write it down like oh I
want this name this location and this
address and is waiting on whatever this
creation this I mean describe yourself
yeah for an ID you granted you know like
you got the picture and you get a paper
and just pause well it goes I mean you
don't like a really good one I mean
cause like like a really good one you
know like you can go higher than that
or I mean you want to because I mean the
one that I got that was like down it's
not really good because I'm adding I
think I got one so like I could just
take it like a copy yeah I would never
take me actually I need to like a play
oh yeah
message for work purposes yeah it's not
gonna be crossing the blue Mexican I did
just for that cuz I you know I can't
really pull up yeah I can't really get a
[ __ ] now
my own I gotta break out the over myself
like you know in the mixing away which
is aspiring if you get a new one well
yeah just the way I just always you know
I was a breaking job you know then I
cook for almost seven years and I've
been you know like just I figure I go
with my hands I just work for the mag
and I just started cooking and and
recently quit my dad was to go to Canada
ppm when we're doing like nine shows
right now whereas this is like crazy
season alluded to the fabric tearing one
of my the holidays of our arm bomb on
high school with them here's the live in
the same building everyone we used to
kick it together all the time we see you
know like Oh Tommy he I guess one home
is hook tomorrow you know work at the
theater he just told me that I was for
delgo I always thought it was a movies I
say my fridge I don't speak no English
at the time like I was like great like a
really pricey tile right there just
chillin shaven
yeah it took me to proceed on where
because there was like a run on
Halloween
to actually meet Bob because he was
doing like a bellows motto right there
like I'm staging yeah I get to me every
day and I would just you know like a
select my first proper story they're
doing like some skeleton numbers if he
was going there I never seen stuff like
that myself you're not too high I'll
actually I remember seeing the movie
like even just like what I mean
like when I seen that when I seen on all
just like I was going out right here so
he just you know came up to me and I get
into those it was the first thing that
Bauer said you know it was like he's
tall you know like so I might buy 10 and
he just got really have because I was
tall and how like I got to be you know
really like you know like get that you
know like
I was you know they always show me that
you know they're always coming that way
I mean just like every property we have
is like over 45 years old and we have a
collection of almost 3,000 minutes which
is amazing a lot of people usually gives
me crap which I'm like I wish I would
have done I just prefer we just get to
play with what Bob created they make
them there yeah new purpose
we are Bob didn't finish and so call
them Arabian Nights it was gonna go
based on a running story and the for the
teens another we're still missing like
the main character which is no Aladdin
seem bad and
the genie and it just didn't got to
finish those and ran out with Polygram
we're gonna do like a big renovation
coming up April for like almost like a
year and I have we're gonna kind of do
some apartment temperature on the pillar
so we're gonna try to feel like Iran
Bernie were right next to it and it's no
Jared oh yeah Attica Lisa yes so little
them forcing us bombing Bob I mean yes
is in his party he like you know also
good he was passed away like in 2008 he
was his business for Ash bar was not the
focus on shows and his business partner
was like financially after he passed
away just kind of like bad last enemy
you know Bob they hold a lot of money
you know to like I mean it was just
mostly you know just some shows and
doing stuff like that in all that money
just cut off to another images you know
what's worse to actually say my phrasing
who actually will rent in and for like
at least we still renting it for like
five years and you know we're like what
I mean know the struggles I remember
since I started so that play survivor
donation we have big money for tickets
I mean was we can we come in our
nonprofit organization and I we don't
like this big process no I never I
usually don't get involve and office I
was my size I should be like another
thing for me I usually do is worry about
the shows in our long is that shows I
live you know I'm happy for them that's
what people comes into a spear and you
know watch the show but for me to like
you know get involve in there and like
in the office and be like I'm well
whether I know are like yeah we're of
course you know we live our you know
people coming to see our shows and you
know we get donations we're hearing
there and to like new projects for like
you know we just recently like a thick
Friday right here and then farmers
market and Echo Park will be like this
big puppet show like in there like in
the middle of the whole thing and you
know there's people that gave us money
to manage desire which is a super cool
like you know to us you know place them
there so I'm doing that what we're gonna
be doing the well the killer you know
like manages to probably keep doing
publishers like in a in a play house
once in a while there's gonna be a baby
what was going where everywhere are you
having them puppet show this Christmas
this holiday season yeah what they
started since last
I'm sorry every day is something really
good prove that you actually do it so
what I'm numb you know like I just been
there the longest you know I'm kind of
you know learn from Bob and I'm the one
teaching you know the people have
whatever pop mean you know they actually
manage to run out to do the show we're
Army which is super amazing because I
mean like well since I've been there I
remember it may have my cell like a day
off or something like that anymore like
I always been in the shows I never seen
like a shore like a science like you
know without info
always been in the shows you know was
that variety right now you know what
attracted me to you was um I saw I saw
that you I saw that on Instagram you
know you have one of the puppets and now
you were playing they come an old song
and you had that [ __ ] roller skating
3,000 beds and that marinade is like I
love clowns my cell like you know I'm
gonna like clowns and that was just our
oldest one he actually has real
realistic things they're like super
heavy Venice Beach this crappy ass fool
bro you have you'll play The Beatles bro
no it's like four four puppets together
as the Beatles
they're controlling all of them Serena's
playing drums yeah and they're playing
guitar yeah
what I show now doing nice shoes right
now start in the forty which is gonna
start on Thursday where I must nights
the one of the you know the best
intentions of Arizona for a now in the
mornings we have a show at 10:30 in the
morning from Tuesday to Friday and a 7
p.m. you know concluded Friday and then
on Saturdays and Sundays when houses are
crazy as this is season we're doing
shows on Saturdays and Sundays in the
mornings a lot of kids from schools go
there on Friday would get nothing most
pose nothing boss yeah well yeah you
know like so yeah Serena's inside
usually be at 2 p.m. so it's gonna be a
10:30 in the morning and 2 p.m. on
Sundays that's good about reached out to
the neighborhood yeah sort of business
if you hear what the neighborhood huh
you teach a lot of people that thank you
girl and I saw a lot of kids you dear
inspire another kid the whirling energy
poverty yeah it comes in you know like
are they like at the beginning
originally seen in the people's I see me
like as a real a prison they don't know
what I do up there
when it comes to other another show
we'll bring her into this warm and we
usually give ice cream and they know
every show
yeah and usually we usually go based on
reservations so I mean like all the
productions he made all the puppets yeah
oh yeah I'm warming up here was a big
production I mean I just Bob you know
what bow was the main guy that will you
know I wanna feel like I wanna that was
like making the shoes for every I mean
you actually start his first puppet show
when he was five years old like in that
town and you know like he's from LA
today yeah like yeah he grew up in LA he
actually grows up his house he still
remains right there in Beverly and
remedy and Westmorland that would he
lived his whole life
yeah his first workshop right behind his
manufacturer puppetry and just building
so when his time is first short when he
was five when he was eight years old
that when he actually creating his own
puppets he was doing shoulder area eight
years old which is like footage we still
have footage of him doing focus is like
little kid just doing publisher like you
know like he has like a little Mickey
Mouse looking one and it looks like to
me it looks like a shower you know yeah
it just is just crazy you know eight
years oh he's doing that already
this whole life is a passed away miss
maybe I mean that's in you know five
twelve years old
what about that do it I mean to us an
important report you yeah it was around
like that's funny man sweetheart like
everything like no like when you're like
you're so great at like us just a little
prior you know so great a stand-up
comedy but not good at finances it's a
music on iTunes cuz we just got a new
computer how do we get the music on that
our iTunes he just backed away like to
let me type in like four years four
years ago he wanted to do what make a
puppet
I found it but he doesn't he does he
makes them but they're not the
traditional everything is mostly for
support at all are fifty strings you can
manipulate maybe fire six so isn't it
mostly everything just to go all the way
of strings but it's something you do get
yourself when you do you get tangles
[Music]
I've been there for less than five
months so where now we trying to teach
them how to like play now you know like
because people they commented they don't
know what we're doing
what is it really like you know I show
around like you know it's like a dragon
feel like this I mean you can really you
know finish something like that one is
you kind of spin the football and stuff
like that so we just trying to you know
like teach uncle's I mean isn't there
break into Joe's go on stage you know
like and do like a Photoshop on all
these people and I didn't do them too
like I year think about to do you know
because I would do dinner that affects
him the main puppeteer when I was you
know working there like he just kind of
never said going so I'm sorry
I kind of night got force into jumping
because but for like the girl was family
to me like the guy they grow up there
like she was like she was kind of scared
of grabbing the main ones which I was
like I just picked it open I'm not
saying that I kind of look just mind
looking because I'm I was had to
practically live with the Pope who would
look I mean where the Papa would do for
me to put like a light if I can I would
just look but learn by looking looking a
lot and when I picked up up but you just
have night became natural features kinda
already had like an idea had it work and
just Bob kind of like perfect me perfect
myself like him do it better than like
cuz I gotta be any I didn't know no
English at all so for me to my
communicate with Bob zero like it was
just not if I have maybe sign language
or something it's like hard for me to
just not matter my psychic to me look at
me just like you know you would do like
a marionette
now we look around me then I was doing
my soul and he will do it that's like
Helen Keller
it was my first job we know we're never
there right here so I just kind of kept
it somehow like me which is nothing but
like you know like money because I was a
high school um you know my little kid
they were just a job both like after
five years you know became tanning just
I make enough passion and just you know
I'm just trying to show off what park
did because I mean it's not my work is
quite a bit
have you made your own puppets no I mean
it takes 300 hours just to make one
I mean discourage using I have made
myself one good just like it's just so
much dedication
you're on Instagram you know karma is a
rule too bro yeah you know can I hit her
up you know like I'm better to the
theater you know she come down it was
for like a run hello I remember it was
Halloween or it was Sega's well I'm
battered down and she brought one on her
pug like I don't wanna you know already
shipping re and you know I told her when
I wanted to do like you know because
it's not it's easy to just cry like a
[ __ ] the ones from the TV and take
care of places and I can't believe you
know cuz the way that I grew up in the
places that I usually go to not really
like kids from there you know like I
usually go to you know your party or
hanging around with the home isn't yeah
I can't really say what I'm focused on
the theater to like places like that
you know to like plays in you know she's
so mean I have everything she bore and I
was just amazed she died for working see
you she told me like you know you should
do one of the this ones into a puppet
and I was like right
anyone all right so I just grabbed one
of the you know the dog that just
brought it apart and just kind of give
it a like a little body movement cuz
what she has is just like a doll you
know just a little like a little statue
in I wanna give it a little boy waiting
just a little movement cuz I don't wanna
feel like a puppet to go to a show there
which is one our hair like let us play a
better and play like give I will make
one of course it will be like a little
better which I'm already talking to her
I'm working so many ideas and we
actually just limit to just below
[Music]
Oh almost half my size
and it was it was like a party just wait
like a brand new body for it I just like
these boots like a little clothes and I
just kind of paint black sir or whatever
yeah faison and everything which is
super cool third thing I just push
I mean for me I mean guys doing they do
crazy flips there's no like actually tie
walk with pyro videos like a serenity
because going on
so I just saw her like you know growl
warning his be put in my hand and just
be able to kind of bring her back into
the world and just kind of finish
towards the end but they didn't go all
the way but it was pretty you know it
was pretty interesting because I never
you know like don't like a mistake like
oh actually I have dropped the pup a
porno like it like important people like
you just happened I don't know it just
kind of weird but it just like stuff you
know you don't plan like recordings like
in a day before in just like oh just do
it just happens right there on aspiring
the second time I would just turn arrows
I didn't play it out as much or viral oh
yeah like you know there's some person
I'm still learning you know like right
now I'm learning that's like go and you
know like I'm just trying to keep that I
laugh as much in the kind of this you
don't see focus around more it's hardly
anybody is some major sometimes when I
take this little guide I've been taking
all these pictures and if you actually
become more famous American becoming of
music videos in there was this guy I'm
fighting one you know he's one of my
homies
you know I got like a little artists and
he did like a missing video he invited
me
[Music]
what well yeah I can't wait man I can't
really wait don't work anything we will
find your way of social media ms-13
probably two or three before good like I
said I you recently just this year just
let it go public which is super about
the time so but you know I would have
liked people more into it which I want I
just want to show today marinate class
you know summer to learn teach
I mean right now seeing I'm actually
going full-time to get around I mean
this all this craziness going on right
now with all this knowledge innovation
and well which are not doing well yeah
no I mean I'm for that to do something
like a little summer camp for kids and
stuff yeah just every case and why is it
just not there for life we always try to
get people to you don't come into it the
airport I cannot for just myself to like
be there full time for all of us you
want to feel like focus for kids and you
know we wanna do like a class for like
almost like 15 kids to like start like
feel like a puppet from ground up for
like the bottom up and then at the end
of the class blew themselves up of the
show you know that's what we're
challenged like the little picture of
Aaron which is down to super quality
time and I come with you you're not
working my new ideas for the theater and
you know you know I could do is maybe
help Dolores missions and their summer
camp kids over there or something like
that yeah right now like we're like this
is like our struggle in like I'm
struggling like maybe like three four
years cuz I'm back in Italy used to be
like a lot of school for like their
school they actually cut their budget
for film trips so that's one that didn't
just somehow last people were and I
would HIGHLY haven't showed like on
Tuesday to Friday I mean come to Sunday
we only have Friday sunny sunny shows
it's not that marginal like three days I
don't you know like six days that's why
I was forced to come and get like a
night job and work in the kitchen but
now you know the slowly-slowly is you
know Christmas isn't speaking of that
well they want me more they're in I was
kind of course with the nighter but I um
but yeah right now this is like you know
that what we're trying to pick up you
know the Nutcracker tonight because we
usually have so Christmas show we should
do one every year one you know holidays
on string will be one year Nutcracker
will be the next year we then do not
crack or Lazio though we didn't want to
get busier but no Kirk is a big name
that allows and that what we can maybe
do like a nice shop or they one day we
have in the morning it's called holiday
on strings
we got like you know elves Santa Claus
Rob
and you know just like the way you :
allowable in tears you know to focus on
you know like you know in ideas and you
know little projects would have here and
there but like the you know was been
there for sure you know I mean
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
system or does
so check it out for everybody don't
forget to get the new vinyl shop
Rebekah's episode will be the last
episode of the year